bonjour je remarque heureux de vous
retrouver ce matin dans le local de rtl
france alors on le disait on est prêt si
on estime que la facture de gaz sur
l'année qui va augmenter de plusieurs
centaines d'euros pour une famille
française moyenne ça fait mal au
portefeuille
elle même si gouvernement va signer un
chèque énergie pour les six millions de
familles qui vont se retrouver en
difficulté alors première question
pourquoi une telle augmentation
jean-marc bas a coûté c'est pas une
petite question à le prix du gaz
augmente parce que la demande de gaz
dans le monde augmente violemment à
cause de la reprise économique après la
pandy la pandémie ça la pandémie avait
calmé le jeu mais depuis l'été c'est
redémarrer très très fort les usines
notamment redémarrer on a fait repartir
des centrales électriques au gaz ou
alors la consommation d'énergie aussi à
augmenter les gros producteurs que sont
la russie la norvège l'algérie le
moyen-orient le qatar là on a fait le
tour du marché mondial eh bien tous sont
débordés par les commandes la demande
est particulièrement forte en europe et
en chine d'abord du coup pression sur
les prix ça bloque partout les prix ont
augmenté de plus de 50% vous le disiez
depuis le début de l'année plus de 12%
mois d'octobre c'est la plus forte
hausse depuis 2013 maintenant alors tout
va dépendre bien sûr des clients parce
que tout le monde n'est pas logé à la
même enseigne à la hausse sera modérée
pour ceux qui n'utilisent le gaz que
pour la cuisson pour faire la cuisine
sera près de 4% pour eux elle sera de 9
% je parle de en octobre qui pour ceux
qui utilisent pour la cuisine et puis
pour l'eau chaude la douche va coûter
plus cher la hausse sera plein pot 14%
pour les foyers qui se chauffent au gaz
qui font la cuisine et qui prennent
l'eau chaude alors une précision cette
hausse s'applique à 3 millions de
consommateurs qui eux ont signé des
contrats à tarifs réglementés pourquoi
réglementé parce qu'ils sont ajustés
tous les mois les autres consommateurs
environ 6 millions signé des contrats
tarifs garantis sur cinq ans ce sont
plus de 6 millions il ne faut surtout
pas qu'ils acceptent un changement de
contrat avant avant l'échéance de leur
contrat sinon il la hausse en plein
champ castex pour mettre des mesures
supplémentaires en octobre que peut
faire concrètement le gouvernement jean
marc a écouté comme souvent un pas grand
chose parce que pour les familles les
plus précaires le gouvernement va va
ressortir les chèques énergie ou des
bonifications exceptionnel c'est ce qu'a
annoncé jean castex il hier il a déjà
envoyé 100 euros cette année var et
envoyé 100 euros avant la mi décembre
ça va faire 1 300 millions d'euros tout
ça il envisage un nouveau chèque de 100
euros en mars de l'année prochaine j'ai
compris mars on n'est pas très loin de
l'élection présidentielle alors il ya
des puits on sera aussi à la sortie de
l'hiver donc il faudra payer la facture
donc alors il ya aussi les taxes sur le
gaz et la tva à 20% ça pèse lourd mais
là le gouvernement ne touchera pas
d'abord parce qu'il a besoin de ses
recettes fiscales et ensuite il faudrait
l'autorisation de bruxelles nord tout ça
est assez compliqué donc d'autant que
derrière il ya aussi la hausse sur les
industriels c'est que les industriels il
les suit aussi cette heureuse et ça
risque de se répercuter sur les autres
produits est-ce que ce qu'on ne comprend
pas aussi jean-marc les autres énergies
augmente comme le pétrole et surtout
comme l'électricité ou aériens phénomène
de contagion d'alignement le pétrole a
lui aussi beaucoup augmenté il valait
hier 80 dollars le baril c'est un petit
record il augmente un peu comme le gaz à
cause de la demande exactement pour la
même raison alors vous avez dans le
monde entier des centrales électriques
qui fonctionnent au gaz ou fioul et
qu'il a fallu relancer à cause de la de
la grâce ou fage delà de la reprise
économique alors l'effet que les tarifs
de l'électricité
ça c'est plus compliqué il augmente
partout dans le monde à cause du gaz et
du pétrole pourquoi parce que là on
relance aussi des centrales alors en
france l'électricité va augmenter
beaucoup moins que partout ailleurs
parce que pourquoi nous avons
l'électricité nucléaire 70 à 80% c'est
l'énorme avantage compétitif de la
france les tarifs de l'électricité
augmentent un peu parce qu'il nous faut
compléter cette production avec des
centrales au gaz mais ça va être de ce
côté-là modérée reste
l'essence reste la facture de gaz ce qui
est intéressant c'est que c'était s'est
invitée dans le débat politique mais les
solutions sont assez contradictoires
c'est vrai la politique s'invite parce
que la facture de gaz et douloureuse à
elle touche tous ceux qui en ces
contrats comme le prêt du prix de
l'essence et les politiques se
souviennent pas mdj les jonas avait
démarré par le plein d'essence sauf
qu'on assiste à un clivage wii est à
celje d'ailleurs à l'enjeu écologique
qui ressort un pendant cette période
pour les uns accepter l'augmentation des
prix de l'énergie c'est une façon
d'obtenir la baisse de la consommation
donc ça permet de lutter contre le
climat mais ça perturbe aussi beaucoup
l'opinion qui veut protéger son pouvoir
d'achat alors les écolos purs et durs
assume les augmentations alors ils le
disent parfois vous avez entendu
s'enlever une rousseau dans sa campagne
dans son dialogue avec avec un jacques
dau mais le reste de la classe politique
est très embarrassé on n'a pas trouvé de
solution miracle pour lutter contre le
climat et pour protéger en même temps la
croissance économique le seul moyen
serait bien sûr les énergies non
renouvelables on peut rêver on en a pas
assez c'est pas sûr que ce soit
suffisant ou alors il faudrait passer
tout au nucléaire là ça ouvre un autre
débat merci beaucoup jean-marc l'édito
de jean marc silvert c'est tous les
mercredis matin dans la matinale verte
et france merci jean marc